(gun firing)
- [Narrator] This video
provided by Kyiv Police
shows officers shooting at drones
flying over the city in mid-October.
The weapons can be seen
in multiple videos.
Here, the device nose dives and explodes
near residential buildings.
Several people were killed
in the attacks that day.
Independent experts who
analyzed images from Ukraine
say Russia has been using
drones provided by Iran;
the Shahed-136 and its smaller
version, the Shahed-131.
(Zelensky speaking in foreign language)
Ukraine is calling for new sanctions
and Western countries
say these drones show
Iran's direct involvement in the war.
After initially denying it,
Iran acknowledged sending
some unmanned aerial vehicles,
or UAVs, to Russia before the invasion.
Moscow has repeatedly denied
using the Iranian weapons,
but there are three types of clues
that confirm their origin:
the design, the way they move,
and the internal components
found among debris
by Ukrainian forces.
First, let's take a closer
look at the structure
of the Iranian Shahed-131 and 136.
They have a triangular shape with wings
and an arrow like extension
where the warhead is located.
(Shahed swooshing)
The weapons, one of which is seen here
in Iranian Defense Ministry footage,
are self-destructing and
designed for one time use.
Meaning after a strike,
they leave behind debris.
These photos taken by
the news agency Reuters
show drone wreckage after an attack
on a fuel storage facility in Kharkiv.
We ask analysts, including a drone expert
from the American organization CNA,
to review the images.
They said these markings,
likely identification numbers,
are similar to those that can be seen
in Iranian handoff
footage of these drills.
The debris found in Ukraine also have
some Russian lettering.
The letters can be seen
on the tips of the wings,
which appear to have the
same shape and structure
as the Iranian drones.
In addition to their appearance,
analysts say the way
Shahed-136 and 131 drones move
is a distinct characteristic.
Here's that footage from
Iran's Defense Ministry,
showing one of those
drones taking a sharp angle
before hitting a target.
In a video posted to social media
from an October 17th attack in Kyiv
and verified by the news agency Storyful,
the drone can be seen
taking a similar sharp tilt
before it's obscured behind a building.
Another video filmed
in Kyiv on the same day
shows a similar nose dive
maneuver before an explosion.
(gentle music)
Key clues can also be found by looking
at the internal components
of these drones.
On the right side is a photo that,
according to Israeli intelligence,
shows the engine of the Shahed-136 drone
being displayed in Iran in October 2014.
We couldn't independently
verify the image.
The analyst told us it looks consistent
with what Iran has disclosed.
And on the left is a
Reuter's photo that shows
an engine recovered
from a strike in Ukraine
in October 2022.
Experts who review these images say
they both appear to be Mado MD550S,
the model that's used in
Shahed-136 Iranian drones.
The copper color rotors
and general structure
are very similar.
Other internal components
of drones found in Ukraine
can be linked to Iranian manufacturers,
according to Conflict Armament Research,
a private UK organization
that tracks illicit
arms and conflict zones.
This panel, seen in a photo of debris
taken at the site of a strike in Ukraine,
contains the same layering of materials
as in other Iranian made UAVs,
according to the group.
The group says this honeycomb meshing
is distinctive of Iranian
drones they've documented.
It's this part sitting between
two layers of fiberglass
which is meant to strengthen
the body of the weapon
without adding too much weight.
Other Iranian characteristics include
handwritten serialization numbers
and stickers that can be
seen on the same panel,
said experts who viewed the pictures.
Russia says it uses its
own drones in Ukraine,
but none of the known
models made in Russia
have the same characteristics
as the drones seen
in the Kyiv strikes,
according to analysts.
The only self-destructing
drone of similar shape
that's produced in Russia is called KUB.
It can be seen in this
Russian handout footage.
KUB drones couldn't be used in the strikes
on Kyiv in October, analyst say,
because they can't travel
farther than roughly 40 miles,
and Russian forces were stationed
more than a hundred miles away
from Kyiv on October 17th.
In comparison, the Shahed
drones have a range
of at least 550 miles, according to Iran.
The KUB is also smaller than the drones
Ukrainian officials say
were found in Ukraine.
This still image of
Russian military footage
shows the scale of a KUB,
whereas this is the size of
the drones found in Ukraine
as seen in footage from
Ukrainian officials,
as well as images of
debris found in Kharkiv.
(gentle music)
Ukrainian officials
say Russia has launched
more than 300 Iranian drones
targeting civilian buildings,
as well as key energy infrastructure,
causing blackouts and
concerns about heating
ahead of winter.
Kyiv says it was able to
shoot down many drones,
but is asking for more help from the West.
Russia's Ministry of
Defense didn't respond
to a request for comment about the use
of Iranian-made drones in the war.
- We're also working
together to impose sanctions
on those supporting President Putin's war.
That includes Iran.
- [Narrator] The European
Union has already imposed
new sanctions on Iran,
and the US has hinted at
more penalties in the future.
But these attacks also highlight
that despite sanctions,
in recent years, Iran has
built one of the world's
most successful drone fleets.
(gentle music)